- IT WAS EXCITING FOR ME,
BUT FOR JACK, WELL,
HE HAD SPENT HIS WHOLE LIFE
DREAMING OF THIS MOMENT,
NEVER REALLY BELIEVING
IT WAS WITHIN REACH.
LIFE IS TRULY FULL OF SURPRISES.
- I LOVE THIS.
- YEAH.
- AND I LOVE YOU.
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING ME ON THIS TRIP.
- AW, DAD.
- AND, FORREST,
I WANT TO SEE YOU
GET BACK TOGETHER
WITH MY DAUGHTER.
- AW.
- I DO.
AND AS SOON AS WE'RE OFF
THIS SPACESHIP,
I'M GONNA DO EVERYTHING IN MY
POWER TO MAKE SURE THAT HAPPENS.
A DAUGHTER DOESN'T LISTEN
TO ANYONE MORE THAN THEIR POP.
BELIEVE ME.
- OKAY.
- TEN, NINE...
all:
EIGHT, SEVEN, SIX,
FIVE, FOUR, THREE, TWO, ONE.
- INITIATE LAUNCH.
- THAT'S ONE SMALL STEP
FOR MAN--
- NO.
JACK!
- ALTITUDE, 300,360 FEET.
WELCOME TO SPACE.
[all screaming]
- OH, MY GOD.
- OH, NO!
NO, JACK!
JACK!
- OH, MY GOD, IS HE--
- JACK, YOU CANNOT BE DEAD!
THERE'S NO WAY!
YOU GOT TO TALK TO SUZANNE!
JACK, YOU GOT TO TALK
TO SUZANNE!
OH--OH, NO.
BUT HE WAS DEAD.
MY DEAR VIEWER,
IT SADDENS ME TO SAY
THAT JACK'S TRAGIC FAILURE
TO FASTEN HIS SAFETY HARNESS
HAD ENDED THE LIFE
OF THIS EXTRAORDINARY MAN
AND CAST A HORRIBLE PALL
OVER THIS JOURNEY INTO SPACE.
BUT THE JOURNEY WOULD GO ON.
- GUYS, I'M REALLY SORRY
TO DO THIS,
BUT I'VE KIND OF PROMISED
TO PROMOTE PRODUCTS,
SO, UH...
STEAK 'N SHAKE--
WHERE THE STEAKBURGER'S
ALWAYS OUT OF THIS WORLD.
U-HAUL--
WHETHER IT'S ONE SMALL STEP
OR ONE GIANT LEAP,
U-HAUL WILL GET YOU THERE.
KRISPY KREME--
ALL RIGHT, GUYS,
WHO BROUGHT THE DOUGHNUTS?
HUH?
- MY FELLOW TRAVELERS HAD FORKED
OVER A LOT OF MONEY
FOR THIS ONCE-IN-A-LIFETIME
EXPERIENCE,
SO YOU COULDN'T BLAME THEM FOR
DOING WHAT THEY CAME HERE TO DO.
- SO...
- WAIT. ARE--ARE YOU...
- I DON'T KNOW.
- OH, MY GOD.
OH, MY GOD.
I CAN'T BELIEVE
THIS IS HAPPENING.
BRYCE.
- WILL YOU MARRY ME, CARRIE?
- OH, IT'S GORGEOUS.
OF COURSE I WILL.
I LOVE YOU SO MUCH.
IS THIS ON TAPE?
- DID WE GET IT ON TAPE?
- WAIT. WAS THAT--
- UH...
- WAS THAT BODY IN FRONT
OF THERE THE WHOLE TIME?